PROFESSOR: So let's
talk about the transfer
of respiratory pathogens, and
in particular, contagious
pathogens such as
viruses and bacteria,
that infect the
respiratory system.
The way that such pathogens
are normally transferred
is through droplets which are
emitted by respiration, which
could be by just normal
breathing, coughing, sneezing,
et cetera.
And so here is a sketch
of an infected person who
is undergoing respiration and is
emitting droplets into the air.
And so let's think about what
is the fate of those droplets,
what it could be.
So one possibility is if
the droplets are very heavy,
they're just going to
settle to the ground.
And then they may
collect on the ground
or on some other surface.
And then somebody else
could touch that surface
and transmit it,
perhaps by touching
their eyes or some other--
or their nose or some
bodily entrance point.
And that sort of transmission
is called fomite transmission.
So these dried up
bits of droplets
on the surface are
called fomites.
And this mode of
transfer would involve
settling of those droplets to
the surface, to a surface, OK?
Now, another possibility is
that the droplets kind of float
around, and if
they're small enough,
they might actually evaporate
and they might disappear.
So they might evaporate.
And at that point, if
there's a pathogen in them,
that pathogen may
still be around,
but perhaps if it
loses enough fluid
it's going to lose
its viability.
And so perhaps those
droplets would be eliminated.
And then finally,
there are droplets
which undergo neither
of these and remain
floating indefinitely, or at
least for long periods of time,
let's say for
hours, in the space.
And these are called
aerosol droplets.
So these are droplets
that are very small.
They don't really settle in
a reasonable amount of time.
But they're not necessarily
evaporating either.
And so they are present.
And if another person is
here, they can very easily
breathe in those droplets, OK?
Now, how do we know
which of these outcomes
is possible for droplets that
are emitted from respiration?
So what it really depends
on at the simplest level
is the size of the droplet.
So the droplet fate
depends on its size.
So why don't we do
some simple estimates
of these different processes?
So the first would be
looking at settling.
So the settling time
from a height L,
which might be the height of a
person, a typical number that's
taken is 2 meters for a
settling problem like this.
It's given by the
following formula,
assuming we have
so-called Stokes'
law of settling is
valid, which it usually
is for small droplets.
And that would be that--
I'll just write
the formula first.
2 rho g R^2.
So basically, there's a 9/2.
L is the height which
they're going to fall.
So basically this is L. And mu_a
is the viscosity of the air,
rho is the density of the
air-- or density the droplet,
excuse me, of the liquid.
And g is the gravitational
acceleration,
and R is the size
of the droplet.
So the size of the droplet
is R -- or that's the radius.
So what you see here is that
when the radius gets bigger,
the drops fall faster, and
hence the time goes down.
So very large droplets will
very quickly settle out.
Others -- as R goes to
be smaller and smaller --
they might be suspended
and become aerosols.
We also might worry about
evaporation, for the smaller
droplets especially.
And the evaporation time,
again with a fairly simple
approximation of pure
liquid which is evaporating.
Basically, just as it's
getting more highly curved,
the molecules will have a bigger
driving force to be removed.
And if it's a
diffusion-limited process,
which is basically water
vapor has to diffuse away
into the environment, then you
can show the evaporation time
is the initial size
of the droplet, R_0 --
so let's just say R_0
is the initial size.
And maybe here,
when it's settling,
it could still be evaporating.
So R could be varying.
But why don't we
just neglect that
for droplets settling quickly.
Maybe that's roughly
the initial size.
And here for evaporation,
there is a constant,
which I'll call D_bar,
which is just something
that has units of diffusivity.
So length squared per time.
And then (1-RH), where
RH is the relative humidity.
So basically, the tendency
for the water droplets
to be removed from a liquid
droplet end up in the air
has to do with the relative
humidity of the air.
So that's another factor
that comes in here.
So if we plot these
two results, we
arrive at the
so-called Wells curve,
which was first formulated by
epidemiologist Wells in 1934.
And I'll draw that over here.
And the Wells curve
is sketched like this.
It says that if we have the
drop size R_0 on one axis,
and on the other axis we have
the time of settling-- the time
that the droplet
has left the mouth,
then you have basically
two expressions here.
So the settling is
something like this,
where it's a function that
goes to 0, like 1/R squared.
On the other hand,
evaporation is the fastest
for the smallest droplets.
You see that it goes
like (R_0)^2.
So it has a dependence
more like this.
And so basically, these curves
intersect at a certain point
here.
And if you ask yourself,
if I am a droplet of,
let's say, this size here,
then as time goes on,
I hit this point, and
this is where I evaporate.
So for just a pure liquid
droplet, at that time,
that droplet would disappear.
On the other hand, if I
have a larger droplet that's
going to hit this
other curve first,
then these droplets will
settle, because before they
have time to evaporate,
which would require
all the way going
to here, they've
already fallen to the ground.
They may continue
evaporating on the ground,
and you're eventually left
with a dried up residue
of some of the
material that may have
been contained in the droplet.
And then there's a crossover.
And so generically, you
expect this kind of behavior
for droplets that are
evaporating and settling.
So the Wells curve was
first formulated in 1934.
And if we just want to put
some numbers on here, if we're
talking about pure water,
then this crossover
happens around 70 microns.
And the time is
around 3 seconds.
So that gives you
a sense, basically,
of how quickly the larger
droplets are settling faster
than 3 seconds, and then the
small droplets are evaporating
a lot faster.
And by the way, to get a
sense of how fast they are,
if we look at the dependents,
each of these is squared.
So if we want to go by a
factor of 100, if you go to,
let's say, 0.7 microns,
which is 700 nanometers,
it's a factor of 100.
But the time comes in squared.
So it's 3e-4 seconds.
So we're talking
0.3 milliseconds.
So basically, droplets that are
in the 1 micron or below range,
if they're pure liquid, they'll
evaporate extremely quickly.
And conversely, if we
consider much larger droplets,
let's say that are bigger
by a factor of 10 or 100,
that also comes in squared
in terms of the settling
time being reduced.
And so we would then end up with
100, or up to even 10,000 times
smaller settling time.
Although it won't
be quite as small,
because also, the particles need
to accelerate to that speed.
This settling speed here is the
terminal velocity of a drop.
And there is a short
acceleration time
for very small particles.
And for very long
particles, you may still
be actually in that acceleration
time when you hit the ground.
So basically, it might
not be that long.
But basically, the
time, at large times,
is also quite a bit reduced
for large particles.
Now, there's also the humidity
effect, which can be seen here.
So for example, if we're
at 90% relative humidity,
this factor here
is a factor of 10.
So what was on the
order of a few seconds,
if we're at higher
humidity, then
this curve ends up
looking more like this.
And we may follow this
curve a little bit
further and end up with
something like this.
This would be high humidity.
I'll say higher, because
I haven't gone that far.
There's another curve that
I could draw where this even
goes further this
way, and where this
could start turning
into, say, 30 seconds
where that crossover occurs.
But in any case, there is
a crossover at some point.
And at high relative humidity,
the evaporation is slower,
and so we are more following
the settling droplets.
And so this is an
important set of concepts
in the field of aerosol
science involving
droplets, and especially
for respiratory diseases.
But it's still oversimplified.
So recent research has showed
that, in fact, many droplets
that are present
from respiration
do not evaporate on these
kind of fast timescales.
And in fact, they
can linger and can
be way into this small
size range of aerosols
and not disappear.
And it's possible, then, to
breathe them in and transmit
disease with them.
So what's missing here
is that the droplet fate
depends not only on the
size of the droplet,
but also on solutes.
So what I mean by that is that,
of course, a droplet coming out
of your lungs and passing
through your pharynx,
your vocal chords, is
not just pure water.
It's even not pure saliva.
In fact, it contains
many other molecules.
So of course, it contains
the pathogens themselves,
which are solids, and
they don't evaporate.
So whether it's bacteria or
virus, some of that material
has to stay behind.
There's all kinds of
organic molecules,
because in fact, the
mucus that comes out
of your lungs as a
non-Newtonian fluid that's
full of macromolecules
of different types.
Those molecules are
usually charged,
as are, in fact, the viruses
and other pathogens as well.
And so there could
also be hydration,
water, so that those
water molecules,
which are not freely in solution
but were strongly interacting
with charge services,
or charged molecules,
and form so-called hydration
shells around those molecules.
And finally, there
could also be salts,
because we all know that
our body is, in many cases,
similar to seawater, and
has fluids which contain
a large number of salts.
For example, sodium
chloride or calcium.
And salts love water.
So in fact, it's been shown that
some respiratory aerosols are
actually observed to be
growing after they're
emitted from the body.
In a humid environment,
water may actually
be condensing onto
those particles
and causing them
to grow, because it
has molecules that love water.
And in fact, these kinds
of molecules or particles
that attract and hold water
are so-called hygroscopic
materials.
And many respiratory--
a significant number
of respiratory droplets
are, in fact, hygroscopic.
So this whole picture of
evaporation settling really
needs to be modified.
The settling part is
going to always be there.
Even a solid particle
which is settling in air
is going to obey this
Stokes settling velocity.
But the evaporation
part of it is certainly
true for pure water, but is
not necessarily the right way
to think about
respiratory aerosols.
So finally then,
I'll just sketch
what happens when
people have measured
respiratory distributions
of particles,
and focusing on
the aerosol range
of the really small particles
that might remain suspended.
So these are particles like
this guy right here, which
are around 1 micron, and
will have settling times
that are on the order of hours.
So those particles
that can linger
in the air for long
periods of time.
And so if we look at
the number of droplets
that we have at
different sizes, and this
is for different
kinds of respiration--
and I'll draw this to
sketch what it would look
like on a log scale.
So here I'll put 0.01 microns,
which is 100 nanometers.
And then I'll put 1 micron,
and then 10 microns, and then
100 microns.
So when you breathe,
speak, cough,
sneeze, you're letting
out a distribution
of particles of all these
different types of droplets.
And those droplets
will typically
contain pathogens, such
as bacteria or virus.
And the way these
things look is because
of these hygroscopic
solutes, in fact,
we don't see that all the little
ones are evaporating it away
in a tiny timescale
like milliseconds,
but in fact, they do linger.
And you do have respiratory
aerosols that can be observed.
And so what these distributions
actually look like,
they tend to have a peak around
half a micron in diameter,
or a radius even smaller than
that would be a quarter micron.
And so they look
something like this.
And if you're
breathing at rest, it
might look something like that.
And actually, the
volume fraction,
if we were to convert
this to a volume fraction,
ends up being around 1e-16 parts
of liquid per volume of air.
So these are very
small droplets.
And you can't see them,
but they're there.
If you're resting breathing, you
might have something like that.
There's also an important effect
of the type of respiration.
So if I start talking,
then it turns out
I'm still releasing quite
a few these aerosols,
but now I'm also releasing
some much larger droplets.
I might even be having--
depending how I'm speaking, and
in fact, my personal physiology
may vary from
person to person, I
might be emitting even more
of these larger droplets.
Or also, the aerosol
droplets as well.
And then there are
other activities,
such as singing
or exercise, where
you're breathing
very heavily, where
you emit even more droplets.
And you can see
vocalizations, singing,
and this can be, for
example, talking,
that those lead
to more emissions.
But the important
thing is that there is
a big population of particles.
In fact, the majority
of particles,
by number or even by volume, is
over here in the aerosol range.
So these are particles
that do hang around.
And they float around the room.
And they can do so for
minutes or even hours,
depending on their size and
the conditions of the room.
These here are the large
drops which will sediment out
according to this formula here.
So the Stokes formula is
still going to be valid
regardless of evaporation.
If we know the size,
we have a sense
of how quickly the
droplets are falling.
But the ones we're really
going to want to focus on
are these aerosols for viruses,
because viruses are small.
Whereas bacteria
are big and they
might have to be transmitting
more of the enlarged drops.
So now let's talk a bit
about the biology of viruses
and bacteria and
see how that might
connect to the physics
of droplet transmission.